tons of beloved Nintendo characters make
their big screen debut in the Super
Mario Brothers movie but viewers have
noticed two missing fan favorites who
consider themselves number one warning
spoilers for the Super Mario Brothers
movie ahead the Super Mario Brothers
movie gets a ton of mileage out of video
game lore and there are Easter eggs
pretty much everywhere you look for
example a toad blows into a video game
cartridge like how people would do with
the NES or N64 when it wouldn't work for
some reason
however it's a Brisk 90 minute run time
there are some bits of Mario mythology
that didn't make it into the movie and
perhaps nothing is as disappointing as
the exclusion of Wario and Waluigi
granted many other characters in the
orbit of Mario have yet to make their
big screen animated debut such as Daisy
and Bowser Jr but Wario and Waluigi have
a unique idiosyncratic appeal to them
and people are no doubt wondering when
they were going to show up that's
especially true since Mario and Luigi
have an antagonistic relationship with
their former co-worker Spike he could
have easily been Warrior and Mario fans
along with other people who love the
Wario and Waluigi memes all over social
media would have lost their minds but of
course the two arch Rivals are the Mario
Brothers could still get their moments
there are naturally many places the
franchise can go as far as sequels the
post-credits scene hence that Yoshi will
be involved in some capacity next time
around Bowser is still around though
tiny and logged in a cage but a sequel
should explore other antagonists and
other facets of this realm and there
would be no better villains for a second
that Super Mario Brothers movie than
Wario and Waluigi Wario was a childhood
acquaintance of Mario and as shown in
the Super Mario Brothers movie Mario and
Luigi got picked on in their youth the
movies could reveal that Royo is one of
those bullies though other stories have
usually portrayed him as having been
jealous of the more popular Mario and a
movie sequel could go in a lot of
different directions with him so they
travel to the Mushroom Kingdom to get
back at their Rivals they could even be
the ones responsible for letting Bowser
out of his imprisonment leading to a
team-up while potentially exploring
other lands or galaxies making it so
that while young Waluigi come from
Brooklyn would also be an intriguing
development by forcing Mario and Luigi
to confront their Roots by the end of
the Super Mario Brothers movie the
brothers are living in the Mushroom
Kingdom after finally earning the
approval of their father they appear to
have finally found contentment in their
lives but their past could come back to
haunt them in a big way with a decade of
games has no shortage of stories to pull
from and characters to include
[Music]